>> Where do you see the place of
bioethics in the future of genetics in personalized medicine?
>> I actually think that bioethics and especially a knowledge
of genetics is increasingly important. Because
you know, bioethics as a concept originated. As an idea
of how to protect participants in research and consumers
of healthcare. People who don't have all of
the training and the information held by the
physicians and the researchers who are you know,
bossing them around. Standing there in white coats looking
scary and saying give me your blood, I'm
going to go do great things with it. It's
important in order to protect autonomy that people
have. As we've talked about, informed consent. You need
to have the information going into a study. But
I don't think protecting informed consent is just about giving
someone a form when they're coming into a study,
and saying. This is exactly what we're going to do. This
is what you're going to experience. Do you sign on
the dotted line? Okay. It's about making sure that people
have the tools to understand their participation in such
an area, in such a venture, in the first place.
And that's by ensuring that people are educated
about genetics, about personalized medicine, about the possibilities
that their future and their genetic code actually
hold. What that actually means for them. The
level of predeterminism or not, that this information
actually applies. And, well, I'm perhaps a little
bit biased in favor of the study of
bioethics because I think it is super fun and
interesting and really important. But. You know,
science is advancing at a pretty breakneck pace.
And you know, we won't always get out in front of it like with Gina. But
someone needs to be paying attention and you know, you never want to say, stand
in the way of any kind of scientific
advancement. I don't think that's at all what
the study of the intersection of ethics and science is about.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But insuring beneficial and responsible use I
think is critical to respecting the people who make research possible. So my
background, I came to bioethics as a philosophy major as an undergraduate. I,
I began studying human rationality, mostly, and philosophical
conceptions of understanding individuals as rational beings
and what your ethical duty is to
a rational being are. That led me
into studying informed consent and medical ethics
because I found it fascinating. I mean
especially how you get informed consent. How
you get any kind of consent from
someone who isn't rational, was formerly rational,
is never rational. Fun questions.
>> Yeah seriously.
>> and then that in turn led me actually to becoming a lawyer.
Because I realized that law is the tool that you're actually going
to use to make sure that people who cannot advocate for themselves
are nonetheless protected. You know, the best advice I can give to learning
bioethics is just be open to figuring out what the next
weird issue is going to be. And learn all you can about it.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> That's why bioethics is fun, right? It's sort of a, a mix between
hard nose practicality and science fiction. You're paying attention to, what
could go wrong and how do we stop that or you know, aspirational
fiction. What, what's not great right now? How can we make it better?
>> Rachel thank you so much for coming in.
>> Thanks for bringing me in.